there's a very interesting article in
the new republic which we're going to
link to
the article is by matt ford and we've um
we've talked about matt ford's work
before and it's often very very good
and in this new republic piece matt ford
talks about the reality that there is
quote no real substantive defense to
these charges the charges against donald
trump
americans watched trump spread lies
about the elections
for months before the riot he warned in
dark and ominous terms that the country
was
in danger and his supporters needed to
fight back trump said at a rally
outside the capitol on january 6th
you'll never take back our country with
weakness
you have to show strength you have to be
strong we have to come to demand that
congress do the right thing
and only count the electors that have
been lawfully slated
lawfully slated he also even praised his
supporters
after they trampled themselves and beat
up police officers as quote
very special so this is a situation
where the facts are abundantly clear
and yet donald trump is going to portray
himself as the victim in these
proceedings
the main line as matt ford writes of
defense from trump's lawyers
is that the impeachment trial is in that
invalid because trump no longer holds
federal office
but also that trump really here is
actually the victim
trump has been victimized on free speech
grounds
trump has been silenced trump isn't
being allowed to speak
this is a form of censorship cancel
culture
blah blah blah blah blah and that trump
is being by tried in this manner
stripped of first amendment protections
now of course
that's a ridiculous argument uh house
managers
already put out a brief about this and
they explained that the first amendment
is there to protect
americans from having their free speech
uh
infringed upon or curtailed by the
government
it's not there to protect members of the
government
from their speech having consequences
speech
has consequences that's part of free
speech
and so the at its core
this is simple gaslighting and i know
that at this point there's so many
people particularly on the american
right
who instantly become triggered when the
term gaslighting is mentioned
this is not uh this trial is not going
to be about
the trump attorney team putting together
a credible
defense the entire idea of trump as
victim
who has lost his free speech rights is
about
putting up a smoke screen so that
most i don't want to say all but most
republican senators will see if any vote
to convict
most republican senators can vote to
acquit
and hide behind this and say it wasn't
and actually part of today being about
whether the trial is constitutional is
set up
so that you can have republican senators
vote to acquit and say listen i didn't
even
think this was constitutional i did my
duty i think the entire thing was
farcical
it was unconstitutional and i voted to
acquit and
this is a very common thing that bullies
do it's a common thing that narcissists
do
they are the perpetrators but they
pretend to be the bullies
authoritarians are always the victims
strong men
are always pretending to be the
aggrieved and we've seen it with kim
jong-un
we saw it with hugo chavez they are all
endlessly the victims forever and ever
and that's what donald trump will try
starting today at his impeachment trial
through lawyers by arguing the entire
thing is unconstitutional trump's out of
office
this all can't happen once we get to the
actual trial
they will argue that this is a matter of
of speech and censorship
and trump is being victimized here by
you know take your pick
the media democrat whatever just pick
pick whatever you want
um and at this point you i would be
surprised if you were surprised
because donald trump has been playing
the victim forever during the 2016
campaign
he was constantly whining about how
unfair everybody was to him the media is
unfair democrats are unfair nobody's
treating him
uh properly and uh there i mean i have a
i have a sort of um i don't know
a sort of macabre detached curiosity
to see how wacky and deranged the case
made by trump's defense lawyers
is going to be and by the time you
listen to today's show by the time you
watch this clip we will probably already
have a sense of it because the
impeachment trial starts today we will
have coverage and much more about this
on the david pakman show instagram page
make sure you're following us there at
david pakman show we will take a quick
break
and be right back after this if you are
anything like me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other
fees or copays there are so many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video